one of the newest trends in
entertainment
involves stories about self-made
entrepreneurs who found a way to get
rich using nothing but their imagination
and a little bit of [ __ ]
now you've seen these stories in places
like the dropout inventing anna or the
joe rogan podcast now while these
charlatans have managed to capture the
world's attention it's important to
remember that white people are not the
only ones capable of elaborate scams
there's a long history of
african-american trailblazers who paved
the way for these white rascals so
tonight we celebrate some of the
forgotten heroes of hoax the founding
fathers of flim flam the best bsers in a
segment we call the wall of great black
scammers
this wall is full of america's greatest
blackest scaminess scammers like mary
ellen pleasant
born around 1814 mary was a poor white
cook in san francisco who toiled with
black workers in boarding houses
restaurants laundries and even stables
now no one could understand why this
white woman was so beloved by her black
co-workers now it turns out that mary
actually owned all those businesses and
became one of san francisco's biggest
real estate investors by eavesdropping
on her rich customers and investing her
money the way they did which is a pretty
good scam for decades she used her money
to fund the underground railroad moving
escapees to california and hiring them
to build new lives as free people but
after the civil war ended mary revealed
her biggest scam she wasn't really a
white ally
she was a black lady the whole time
now
lots of people pull scams but instead of
asking you to send money to a nigerian
prince she used her skin to make this
country a better place mary ellen
pleasant we salute you
hey look at who this guy is it's henry
brown now henry brown was an enslaved
man who convinced a white dude to mail a
package for him to philadelphia now you
might not know this but in 1849 very few
enslaved people had time to go to the
post office the lines were really long
and there was no way they could get it
done on their lunch break so
when this giant package arrived at some
office at the office of some
abolitionists in philly guess what was
in it
henry brown was hiding in that box the
whole time like a stripper and a cake
and since pennsylvania was a free state
once henry got there he was no longer a
slave that's why henry box brown the man
who mailed himself to freedom is one of
the greatest black schemers of all time
now
this is julius caesar stratford he was
born into slavery but one day out of
nowhere he dropped a bomb on his master
he was free now how well it was illegal
for enslaved people to learn how to read
but julius sweet talked his master's
daughter into secretly teaching him then
he forged a travel permission slip fled
to canada where slavery was illegal and
got a hold of papers that allowed him to
free himself his wife and his son then
he went back to his master's plantation
and did just that this man traveled to
the south during slavery to free his
wife and child i wouldn't go to the
south today to meet beyonce
friggin that is true love it's also an
a-plus award-winning scam now we
couldn't find a picture of julius so we
just used this old-timey picture of a
different world star and whitley's one
true love kadeem hardison
you got scammed
you were scammed look at this this is
barbara rose johns in 1951 when she was
just 16 years old barbara tricked the
principal of her high school into
leaving for the day
she then forged a memo from the
principal calling students to an
assembly where she told them that they
should band together and protest the
terrible conditions at their all-black
school the protest that followed led to
a court case that became part of brown
versus board of education which
desegregated schools in america which
means
barbara brought about all that change
just by tricking her dumb-ass principal
into leaving the building
it's like a cooler version of ferris
bueller's day off but it should be
called ferris bueller fights the power
and finally these two guys scammed
everyone out of a grammy girl you know
it's true millie vanilli were excellent
scammers
folks you can call them innovators you
can call them trailblazers but i call
them
the wall of great black scammers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you